let's talk about a bombshell Newsweek
article by curt i can Wald who's uh been
on the show before we've had the
backstory of the Trump business
conflicts between Trump as the president
and Trump as the CEO of is a big real
estate in business empire we've talked
about this blind trust that Donald Trump
clearly doesn't know the definition of
planning to turn over businesses to his
kids which would make it neither blind
nor trust and Curt I can Walt has
outlined that this is not merely how do
I want to say it a sort of theoretical
or or academic conversation this is a
real today conflict let me give you one
example as Kurt I can wald rights in
Newsweek brutal Filipino president
Rodrigo Duterte is championing the
killing of suspected criminals of
suspected drug dealers and suspected
drug addicts in the streets of the
Philippines this is fate basically
vigilante death squads we've had a
report that Donald Trump spoke to
President do today told him that he
supports his fight against drug dealers
and actually invited him to the White
House the Trump campaign was asked about
this and the Trump campaign has issued
no denial whatsoever that's already
insane now here's the business conflict
trump tower at century city in makati
philippines is almost complete
ninety-four percent of the condo units
have deposits down donald trump jr and
eric trump went to the building to
shovel dirt in a ceremony there is this
picture over my shoulder tells you
Ivanka Trump's jewelry is expected to be
available in the mill in the building
this project is going to be a stream of
millions of dollars from the Philippines
during the trump presidency if relations
with the Philippines go south the
project might have problems not exactly
a blind trust is it and as Kurt I can
Walt points out in his Newsweek article
note that the Trump family has a huge
financial interest in do tear days
deadly vigilante justice campaign
rooting out crime or perceived crime in
the Philippines is good for real estate
values something that Donald Trump and
his
family are directly financially invested
in and this is so complex because even
if Trump leaves this project on paper
even if Trump's business partner is
removed as the special envoy to the
Filipino president duterte Trump still
going to know he has a building there of
course this would have the potential to
impact Trump's dealings with this brutal
brutal president uh so number one
there's some really specific
constitutional questions here we know
about the emoluments clause we know that
according to both Bush and Obama ethics
lawyers Donald Trump as it stands today
would be in violation of the
Constitution if you were not to resolve
these conflicts before taking office but
this is also a national security risk
this gives a brutal foreign leader
leverage over Donald Trump and for all
the conspiratorial talk from Alex Jones
about global estores as he would say
globalist um this is a real problem this
is this is the globalist guy if you look
at the appointments that Donald Trump is
making if you look at the worldwide
business interests and it's not just the
Philippines China is one of the top to
export destinations for the Philippines
if you go to trade war with China you
are also hurting the Philippines which
will hurt Donald Trump's personal
finances and Trump is talking very tough
about this trade war but there's also
the reality that that trade war might
hurt Trump's finances uh directly but
one other story about this I told you
the week before last i believe about
Donald Trump's conversation with the
president of my home country of
Argentina within three days of that
conversation at a stalled 35 story
office building in Argentina was
reportedly moving again and that is just
yet another way in which the relations
with a lot of these countries relate
directly to Donald Trump's checkbook or
not checkbook to his bank account and to
that of his kids this is a national
security risk excellent excellent
reporting by curt i can walled in
newsweek let's take a break i'm on
twitter at d pakman send me your
thoughts on this